après la thaïlande le cambodge est
devenue la destination par excellence
pour le tourisme sexuel et
particulièrement pour les pédophiles des
pays riches il ya une équipe d'une heure
sur terre qui a suivi la piste d'un
pédophile québécois condamné au cambodge
sans que le gouvernement canadien ne
soit intervenue alors pour en parler je
reçois journal estime un côté bon jour
yvan merci ce matin alors on sait qu'il
ya plusieurs pays dont le canada qui ont
voté quand même des lois qui permettent
de condamner pour ce que c'est criminel
là qui ont commis des actes à
l'extérieur du pays basque ont elles
fait vraiment c'est la question en fête
à laquelle on tente de répondre dans ce
reportage fait ce qu'il faut comprendre
que cette loi était adoptée par le
canada mais par plusieurs pays
occidentaux
ça visait justement à s'attaquer à ces
pédophiles qui choisissent leur
destination dans des pays où on sait que
du laxisme des pays du tiers-monde où
les lois sont pas nécessairement très
rigide où les policiers sont facilement
on peut facilement les corrompre donc il
fallait que les pays occidentaux se
disait il fallait que nous on agisse
pour justement être responsables de nos
pédophiles parce que personne ne protège
les enfants là bas il s'agit de noix qui
n'était pas assez il ya 15 ans portant
seulement cinq canadiens qui ont été
arrêtés pendant toute cette période donc
évidemment ça soulève plusieurs
questions du côté de la grc nous on ne
suivit le cas d'un québécois là-bas et
agressé deux fillettes 9 ans et 11 ans
il ya des organismes à but non lucratif
là bas qu'ils ont suivi parce que les
policiers ne faisait absolument rien ces
organismes sont entrés en contact avec
la grc et pourtant on n'a pas eu
vraiment de suivi pas eu de réponses du
côté de la grc donc est ce qui eut même
du côté de la grc du laxisme je propose
peut-être d'écouter un extrait du
reportage vous allez voir à quel prix à
quel point les pédophiles on les
retrouve un peu partout d'abord au
cambodge et vous allez voir le travail
que fait cet organisme qui remplace en
quelque sorte les policiers
des adultes à la recherche d'enfants ici
on en voit partout dans les restaurants
les hôtels les vues ils agissent au
cambodge en toute impunité
ses agresseurs comme daniel lavigne
savent que les autorités locales
s'intéresse très peu alors
d
enfin en fait la situation est tellement
alarmantes sur le terrain qu'à défaut de
policiers dédiés à la cause au cambodge
c'est la somme l'inde qui dirige action
pour les enfants
une ong française a décidé de
pourchasser lui même les touristes
sexuels qui s'arrête dans son pub
dans vos canada bien peu d'interventions
après ces personnages aux états unis on
peut aussi traduire en justice et
émettre à présent les pédophiles quand
est arrêté dans d'autres pays c'est une
loi qui est similaire à celle du canada
mais vraiment du côté des états unis on
agit est ce qu'il ya d'important pour
les etats unis c'est d'envoyer un
message à tous ces touristes sexuels
regardez si vous effectuez un crime dans
un autre pays on pourra vous jugé aux
états unis pour ce crime mais là ce sera
les peines des états unis et non celle
de ces pays au cambodge en trop pour une
agression sexuelle quelqu'un peut avoir
seulement un an de prison alors les
états unis ça peut aller jusqu'à 30 40
ans et justement ce québécois là qui a
été suivi au cambodge où est-il
aujourd'hui à ce moment il est détenu en
ontario parce qu'après notre tournage
les policiers de la grc imaginer ont
réalisé qu'ils étaient recherchés au
pays parce qu'il a agressé supposément
ici aussi deux fillettes dont il était
en attente de son procès en une heure
sur terre ce soir merci vent au revoir